[Music]
gotcha [ __ ] hi family-friendly Felix
from BuzzFeed here I'm at BuzzFeed
reporting live with my friends Jack and
Mark god damn it mark what I can what
active or family-friendly now none of
that gay [ __ ] ball can farts hilarious
by the way this video is sponsored by
out of ideas production so if you could
leave a like submerged I like you have a
99 percent chance of the dying one day
now I know what you're thinking I'll
hand fart ain't nothing special about
that boy you haven't heard of hand fart
master the greatest channel on all of
YouTube
[Music]
shut up I'm not crying it's just so
goddamn beautiful he'll honored to be
living in the same age where I can enjoy
and foreign masters beautiful music but
I've noticed how Hanif art master he's
always so he's always so sad in all his
videos with our steady look why hand
pardon master why are you so sad you
have a gift a gift from the God why is
he not enjoying it I'll tell you why
because there's a stigma against people
with hand farting skills okay
he's practically the Mozart of our time
and people probably are just hating on
him this is the song I want played on my
funeral by hand fart master himself
it's Rahner
I like what he did with the tone there
[Music]
in my tray he'll remain within the sound
of silence how the [ __ ] did he do that
though for real i legit can't even get a
[ __ ] sound
I can't I just can't [ __ ] do it
surely there's some tutorial that will
teach us hey [ __ ] then we're going to
show you a tutorial of how to import
this is Ryan Padgett other than that
bear trap on a YouTube channel so check
it out because it's kind of like rocket
League yeah others should be feeling
peter has pretty cool hold on hold on
there's Ryan just riding up a rocket
League on his YouTube channel are you
serious right now that has never been
done before my god why am I watching
this [ __ ] I need to watch Ryan play
rocket League
check out Ryan's channel my god finally
you [ __ ] lie you [ __ ] liar Ryan I
wanted to see some rocket League
gameplay the most unique idea of a
gameplay video channel I have ever seen
god dammit god dammit I'm so angry I
wanted to see well kilig [ __ ] alright
[ __ ] it let's just watch a stupid video
stupid stupid Ryan picture I hate you
Ryan
okay so the first step is get your hands
and um what are you smiling about Ryan
were said to see reacts sound weird
though the total for this guy named
Jerry Phillips and he's kind of hand
passports it's basically for your hands
there's nothing funnier I'll shut the
[ __ ] up especially when you put your
hands together and make fart noises it's
kind of weird but it's what it is trying
to learn here so it's basically you just
can't put your hands in like right here
faces we're hearing he doesn't differ
one here for me that's my right hand and
so I put our hands up like this so you
do that Jay get these a shot right I'll
stop [ __ ] sake right I'll give you two
years and you put them right into your
thumb both get record this is my right
hand okay all I think here is except
myself
person you're getting it right here yeah
so putting it there and then putting my
thumb over here okay my name is shot and
put over there so my hand must weed my
hand like this so my hand looks like
this it closer up see how it looks
so and you basically just trying to push
that air through your hand about so
right here you have press the air
starting from here to go cross from here
let me worry what you did air flow to
your hand
so basically if you have to get like I
showed you the beginning and this is
just fish we they're through it's kind
of hard because yeah I thought the air
flow here and kind of push it all the
way younger here solely from here so
here are tsai-tien okay here we go
alright here we go the moment I've been
waiting for my entire life
[Music]
did you hear that [ __ ] replay that [ __ ]
son
I have tried for [ __ ] hour that was
amazing
[Music]
just [ __ ] yes mom mom come back today
finally I'll be the first youtuber ever
that actually has to tell him I'm
getting good son I've really been trying
all [ __ ] day shut the [ __ ] can you at
least get a little bit smushed I like
wait you can put it in the sink and
that's better
this is what you do not handle it so
maybe like a little bit it's easier if
your hands away maybe that's why I'm so
bad at it I think that it was a here's a
little look at my hand away okay yeah oh
well job is earlier how you can throw so
much lady yeah yeah yeah house so this
kind of he's just doing it along this
yeah you know what my secret was I've
been doing it this way all the time but
then I switch to this way and all of a
sudden it just worked what if I get my
hands real way I bet I can make the
sickest ooh ooh I think I understand now
I think I understand you have to price
it to get up there through the hole he
was right all along but I was like how
do I do that
so if you have ungodly sweaty hands you
can finally make that come to use you
know so many girls switch hands I hold
and I'm like oh dude you you're so
sweaty disgusting like you need to get
that checked up little did I know they
had a gift
I couldn't make music with this [ __ ] as
well now I know hand fart master is
pretty good at hand farting and I know
you know I am as well
but that
one man one man which is basically the
Jesus Christ of the hand farting nixar
zero five look at this guy living legend
right here boy
[Music]
thank you Mark and now Jack how did he
go so high with the fart it's incredible
a true master he's my sensei
I love him this [ __ ] has only 29
21 subs right but you look just look at
the devotion of his uploads this
[ __ ] just doesn't do a couple
okay
living legend living goddamn legend
right here look at this [ __ ] he's even
been on Jimmy Kimmel notice how there's
no microphone extra meter it's
incredible it's truly is incredible he's
been playing with his hands for 37 years
smash that like button and you get a 99%
chance of dying one day remember to
subscribe and subscribe and unsubscribe
and subscribe and unsubscribe and
subscribe I'll see you guys in
tomorrow's video and as always brah fast